hey everybody and welcome back to parka
text today I'll be playing highway
hijinks which is a park in a few acres
of flat land according to the
description and as a Dutch person I want
to argue with their definition of
flatland but it's actually a pretty fun
scenario I haven't played it so far but
I've worked on the map a little bit
because this is actually a scenario that
Joshua made but when the developers
decided that they wanted to have
trophies in each of the scenarios they
asked me to add some scenery to this
scenario like the bridge that you can
see there to actually add a trophy which
you can get by the time that you get to
the end of the scenario so lets you see
what this map is actually like and what
we need to do here also I'm sorry about
spoiling what the trophy is gonna be for
this map this was one of the rare cases
where I had to do this though most of
the trophies of the maps were pretty
much already there when they decided to
put the trophy system in place so we
need to get 550 guests in the park have
an overall park rating of 80% and then
there are some optional goals one of
which we can get by the time we get
halfway through the scenario now I think
it's the most interesting about this
park is the fact that we do have a
highway running through the middle of it
which is very similar to an old roller
coaster tycoon scenario called fun topia
although some of the differences are
that while fun topia was already a
prebuilt
park with some rollercoasters and rides
this one is more or less empty and
quote-unquote flat and also it's really
cool is that we actually have some cars
and trucks driving through the middle of
the park here now the goals of this
scenario aren't too difficult but I do
have to say that I might want to get
into some research because we only have
a few flat rides here a few flat rides
here and two coasters and really no big
coasters I'm definitely gonna start out
with some research on roller coasters
maybe on some transport rides as well
because this is quite a sizable park and
I do want to have some way to transport
people around and maybe some water rides
as well because as somebody pointed out
on the second-to-last episode I haven't
built many water rides yet so far I
think the log flume from
misuk oasis was the only one so that's
something that I should focus on a bit
more in the future for now though I'm
gonna get started on this scenario and
we'll see what comes out of it
all right so I'm starting this scenario
by removing some of the paths that the
game has given me not really out of
distrust of path systems that you get
right from the get-go for scenario
although that is definitely something
you should always consider but more or
less because I saw the pond in the
middle of the park here and I figured
that this would actually be a very good
place to center the park around so I'm
building some small boulevards alongside
the water here to make sure that we have
this open space in the middle of the
park centered around the lake so I can
start building rides and buildings etc
around that and kind of start working on
some sort of skyline it's always good
for some sight lines to center around a
water element and then above the
carousel which is the classic first ride
of the park I'm building a roof as well
and coming back to the batavia Kay
episode shout out to somebody called yes
sir Mullen who in the comment section
replied to my whole question about why
these roofs are Co are called Dutch hips
roofs because like he said you
definitely don't see them in the
Netherlands per se they are apparently
very common in Australia and Polynesian
areas the Caribbean etc but you don't
really see them in the Netherlands and
his theory was that it might be related
to the Dutch East or the West Indies
I think he actually referred to the West
Indies but yeah it's hard to keep track
of all of that colonialism but yeah that
was all just speculation as well I still
haven't been able to find out why these
roofs are called Dutch hips roofs
exactly but it's an interesting history
definitely not a very Dutch thing but
for this park I'm not really going for
any specific theme in particular so I
think it works out is it's another kind
of way to build some sort of variation
on the roof over a flat ride so that I'm
still not running out of ideas for these
things and on this side I'm building a
small food court and for the first time
in my entire playthrough I decided to
use the customizable
which are super handy if you're building
indoors like this for one you don't get
any decorations on top of the stalls
sometimes if you put a burger store
inside a building you might get some
parts of the burger popping out of the
walls things like that so you can
prevent that from happening with these
custom stalls but also they can sell
anything that any of the rights or any
of the stores that you've unlocked can
sell so it's really handy for if you you
know want to sell a particular item but
you don't want to build it anywhere in
my case I wanted to sell the stuff that
they sell in the vending machines
because I didn't have a drink store but
I did want to sell drinks so instead of
researching an actual store and hoping
that I could get a drink store
I'm just getting a regular store to sell
drinks which is going to be good because
this can actually be serviced from the
back so that supplies are gonna be able
to be given to this store from the back
which can't happen to a vending machine
you are always gonna have to supply a
vending machine from the front so
logistically this is just a bit better
and then in the store next to it I think
I use the regular store to give it the
the workings of an info kiosk I think so
it's gonna sell park maps so that's
gonna be quite useful as well and then
the other one is one that I also haven't
seen so far it's selling cakes I forgot
which kind of cake it was exactly but I
noticed that not only did it decrease
hunger it also increased happiness
so funnel cakes that's the one so that's
gonna be very handy and then there's
another store which I forgot about but
yeah everything is pretty much covered
by these buildings from Park Maps to
drinks the food I only need to put a
toilet building at some point in the
near future and this is practically one
building and I'm going for a sort of
generic modern building style for this
park and I'm trying to take as much as I
can the materials and colors from the
pre-built areas of this park but at the
same time I didn't want this to become a
drab modernists area so I'm adding some
slight variation and sort of imitating
the look of old town facades but with
some slightly more modern architecture
by having these buildings like this by
having sort of three different facades
even though it's just one building
I honestly personally kind of like that
because for me in general the the
attractiveness of traditional buildings
doesn't per se really come all that much
from their details but really a lot also
from the way that they are laid out and
the scale at which they're built and
their composition so I tend to also just
like modern or postmodern buildings that
follow the same kind of general shape
and try to maybe even blend into their
surroundings in such a way although I
don't want to get too political here
that's just my own kind of flavor or my
own kind of taste in buildings that I
try to add in a little bit here and also
I'm adding a top spin because I do need
to get some intense rides even though
the top spin in the game doesn't really
have very high stats there are actually
going to be some guests who think it is
an intense enough for them so I will
have to build some kind of intense
roller coaster but for now I think it
should be good so I opened the park with
that having the top spin and the
carousel which I forgot to open so far
but that should be a good decent start
to the park and also what I finally
built which I should be building a bit
more in these scenarios is a small open
area with some benches and litter bins
and parasols just as a general outdoor
seating area so far I've kept most of my
seating indoors or just in the same
buildings that the stalls are in but
ending these outdoor areas I think
definitely adds a flair of realism to
the parks because you tend to see these
kinds of areas quite a lot in real theme
parks so they're very good filler as
well I would say to bring different
areas of the park together and then I'm
also adding the jumper flat ride because
that was also one of the few flat rides
that I got right from the start at this
point I'm basically just running the
game waiting for my research to unlock
the next coaster which I didn't yet know
what it was going to be I just
a general area on the on the top left
open therefore the coaster to be built
in and yeah I'm really just waiting
until that is unlocked because without a
rollercoaster this park is never gonna
run a profit and really in general I
would say that's the most crucial thing
about doing scenarios in park attacks
you want to get one kind of
rollercoaster at least right from the
get-go because they tend to make much
more profits than any of the flat rides
which makes sense it's always kind of
been that way but it's actually kind of
difficult to run a profit on flat rides
installs alone so roller coasters really
helped out a lot here although I do like
ending the flat rides to flesh out this
area and so I'm also adding the ferris
wheel there which is just a nice little
addition in that area anyway at this
point I finally unlocked the coaster
which turned out to be the monorail
coaster and at first I wasn't really too
happy with this I was hoping to get some
kind of more typical rollercoaster like
a floorless coaster or you know it's
some kind of steel coaster but this is
quite a niche coaster really but I think
it's a really fun coaster anyway
so I'm just gonna roll with this because
the other ones that I had unlocks are
the wild mouse and the junior which
aren't going to make me enough money so
this one will have to do decided to add
the standard steep lift Hill that you
tend to see on these things but the rest
of the layout is going to be a bit
different because unlike the real-life
monorail coasters of this model which
are all really compact I want to make
this one a bit more spread out and give
it some more interaction with the rest
of the park so I'm starting off with the
steep live tour and then following that
the RMC wildfire drop which we haven't
seen on this type of coaster before but
RMC has done it on wildfire for instance
so I think it might work on this coaster
type into a zero-g roll over the paths
which is just one of the best elements
to have past interaction with a zero-g
roll just looks really cool into a cobra
roll which is another new element for
this coaster type but I think it might
work and then into an airtime Hill and
then some twisted sections before we get
into some block breaks and also the
block break
there's a dive drop which is something
that you tend to see mostly on being a
mooing riders but I think it works out
quite well on this coaster you know it
gives a bit of a slower moment because
these layouts tend to be really fast I
don't know if the friction on these
coasters is entirely realistic although
in real life these are super fast as
well but even here in park attacks it is
really hard to run out of speed with
these coasters they just run at crazy
high speeds so I added the block breaks
in the middle partly to improve the the
throughput of this ride because they are
only one seat across so they're very
inefficient if you don't add enough book
breaks but it's also really there to
slow down the coaster during the middle
of the layouts and prove and add some
time where you can actually catch your
breath because these things are really
fast and intense but yeah after that
dive drop we have some low segments with
a quick over Bank turn into a barrel
roll into a helix and finally back into
the final breaks and since I do have
that extra mid-course brick block break
section as well as the block breaks at
the end of the layouts and they are
spaced out pretty decently I can run
three trains on this coaster which is
absolutely amazing I think this is
actually my first three train operation
in any of the scenarios so far and I
definitely need that because these
trains can only say seat eight people at
a time because they're just so small so
I'm gonna need all of the efficiency
that I can get I know that I haven't
made every coaster in the scenario play
throughs very efficient so far and some
of them could have actually used some
some extra block breaks but with this
one being the first coaster of this
scenario and seeing that I wasn't making
a profit at all before I built this
coaster I really wanted to make sure
that I got the efficiency on this right
and then I make as much money off of
this as I can now into the scenery the
station is quite simple for the first
time I'm using this kind of barn roof
with the slightly less steep roof on the
front I'm not entirely sure how well it
works on this station especially
considering that
the other roof over the station is a
regular gable roof with some flat parts
on the side so yeah I'm not too sure how
much I like the overall roof structure
on this but there's some fun elements in
here
I can definitely reuse in some of my
future playthroughs and finally I'm just
sprucing up the whole area around the
lake a little bit more adding in all of
the fences and the foliage and also
finally the toilet building because I
realized that I still hadn't built the
toilet building at this point so my
guests must have been dying to go take a
Shh although I do have to say I didn't
notice anyone complaining I was checking
the guests thoughts and even though they
were complaining about some vandalism
and some of the parts being dirty and
they were complimenting the wraptor
entertainer as well they weren't
actually complaining about not finding a
toilet anywhere which I thought was
peculiar
maybe I just hadn't run the park long
enough for people to start to having to
go to the toilet but apparently it's
fine if you start the park without a
toilet and only build one later on it's
not too important to notes but for me as
someone who tends to forget placing
toilets it doesn't mean that I don't
have to begin a catastrophe every time I
start a scenario and forget to place
down a toilet again anyway that'll be it
for this time lapse so let's quickly
check how the park is doing so the park
is doing quite well and I'm making sort
of a devilish amount of money at this
point
but yeah altogether this coaster here
definitely saved me because this is
making a very good profit and it's
definitely the only reason why I'm not
losing massive amounts of money at the
moment even the ferris wheel is actually
tanking although not at the moment but
for most of its time it is so yeah it's
definitely the roller coaster that saved
the park here and speaking of roller
coasters when I reached one of the goals
which is the half way go of getting 250
guests I unlocked the Giga coaster and
I'm not sure if actually want to build
that one because it's quite expensive
I'm actually not that great at it either
I don't think I've built many layouts
with it yet so we'll see what I do with
that one or if I end up building another
type of coaster I also unlocked the
tourbillon which is not the greatest
flat ride I have to say because even
though I think it looks amazing I
already have a regular Top Spin in my
Park and this is pretty much just a top
spin on crack so I I'm not sure if I'm
gonna build that one but basically my
plan right now is to expand a little bit
more on this side of the highway
and my sort of in universe lore for how
this park would develop is that this
part is all the old parks everything on
this side of the highways or the old
park so I want to have most of the rides
and buildings in this section and then
at some points they ran out of space to
expand so they bought the land on the
other side of the highway and so
everything on the other side of the
highway will be more of a recent
expansion to the park so it will be I
guess a bit simpler with less foliage
but at the same time going for more
intense and bigger rides and also I'm
probably going to keep this part of the
park quite empty so it being a most
recent expansion in that sense makes
sense I think because I'm trying to also
keep in mind that the guests go for this
scenario is quite low so I can't really
build that much I only need to get to
550 guests so just one or two coasters
on this side of the highway should
pretty much do it I don't really need to
make use of all of this space here now
let's talk about the coaster for a bit
because this thing actually runs
incredibly well and it's the first time
they're actually running three trains on
a coaster I could technically run four
trains on this but then there would
always be one on the book brakes at the
end and it doesn't make the coast of
that much more efficient so let's
actually take a look at how those thing
runs as you can see it's really fast
except in this Cobra bow of course which
is quite tight at the top but altogether
I think it runs a very realistic speed
considering that these things in real
life also run
fast I remember the first time I saw
footage of Wonder Woman or real blazer
either of the two testing and I was
thinking to myself that it would never
run at that speed in real life because
it was looping it was looking absolutely
crazy but turns out that it actually
does run at these speeds for some reason
these rides are just really fast and I
don't know if it's an optical illusion
because of their the small trains and
the small tracks but if you watch off
rides videos of either Wonder Woman or
real blazer you can definitely tell just
how fast these things are so I think
it's realistic although I do have that
sort of special element here of having
this dive drop which is very slow it's
crawling through this inversion just to
give you some extra hang time
so yeah altogether I think the park is
doing quite well for now I'm gonna
expand a bit more into this area and
then we'll see when I'm gonna be able to
build on the other side of the highway
so let's go alright so I decided to
build the Alzheimer's ride which is
something that I should probably use a
bit more in this playthrough I think
it's a very underrated ride it works out
quite well not just in politics but in
real life as well I think it's a really
good filler for the park you know it
fills up space quite neatly and it can
just run between different kinds of
rides but it also fills up your day very
well I think if you're in a less busy
Park and you've already done all of the
rides and you just want to sit down for
a bit but you don't want to sit still on
the bench I personally like relaxing on
one of these rides or you know a gentle
water ride or whatever just in general
the kinds of rides that trip stroll
seems to have way too many of so yeah I
actually really like these things maybe
that's just me it's definitely not a
very popular opinion but they're just
nice so yeah also they usually have a
pretty nice landscape around them so
it's fun to build in parked eggs as well
because they just they can fill up any
different space that you need like if
you have some really awkward space left
that you don't really want to fit with a
flat ride in or that doesn't really fit
for a coaster like this space over here
you could pretty much just come up with
any kind of layout for the
his rights and put some landscaping
around it and call it a day and it
should usually work quite well and with
this one I'm bringing most of the focus
to the station which is just gonna be a
slightly fancy building here with a
small square in front of it which should
hopefully fit a bit with the sort of
English French gardening style theming
of the ride in general just in general
the whole antique cars is is kind of I
don't know why but to me it just seems
to fit that whole aristocratic European
themed quite well sort of the turn of
the century early 20th century kind of
design just because that's the general
period that these cars are from as well
and there really isn't too much to it
either God maybe you can tell that I'm
trying to really push for some kind of
thing to commentate about while I am
building an Alzheimer's right of all
things because these things as much as I
might like them there's really not so
much to them I'm just putting some basic
hedges and trees around this mostly also
to hide the employee path because
actually I don't think that they counts
as a negative scenery item in the same
way that Depot buildings do for instance
so if you show your employee paths I
don't think it automatically you know
makes the theming of a ride really bad
although I'm not sure in that don't
quote me on that
I might be wrong here but in any case I
wanted to actually block this off a bit
because obviously you don't want to see
the employee backstage areas when you're
on this ride and just putting some
fences fences and hedges around it
should generally work to fence all of
that off now in this space next to the
jumper I wanted to put an observation
tower or a launched drop tower or
something like that a tower ride that
fits on a very small footprint and I
kept pushing for my research but I
didn't get any of the rights that I
wanted so eventually I gave up and
decided to put a small food courts and
toilet building in this which is very
close to the food court that I already
had
so actually the only food that I'm
selling in this thing is just one stall
and I forgot what it was exactly but
next to that I have some first aid room
and a toilet as well so it's just
generally a pretty useful building
I think pretzels or no I was selling
donuts in this building there we go I
don't think we got pretzels in this in
this map but yeah that more or less
rounds up the old parts of the park and
now I wanted to start on the new section
on the other side of the highway but
before I did that I needed to get an
extra low now it's because I was running
out of money even though I was earning a
very minut amount of money every month I
wanted to build a Giga coaster or really
a hyper coaster here although
technically I think it's just a mega
coaster I'm not gonna confuse you with
any more terminology I wanted to build
this coaster here and I needed a lot of
money to do that and as you can clearly
tell that one loan was definitely not
enough to do this because this coaster
is insanely expensive not just as a
coaster type but also I'm trying to
build a mega coaster which are usually
pretty huge so it's just gonna take a
lot of money to build that thing so in
the meantime I decided let's just keep
the park running at a good speed and
build a junior coaster because I wanted
to have one of these anyway because I
couldn't just put only very intense
coasters in the park and then hopefully
by the time I'm done with this junior
coaster I'll be still at about the same
amount of money and I can get the extra
income from the junior coaster and
finance my big coaster with this at
least that was the plan that didn't work
out very well in the end spoilers but
yeah that's what I was thinking at this
point in time eventually I just had to
let the game run for a while while I
wasn't doing anything at that point
because I just needed to get some income
to actually finally built the coaster
and building the coaster was way too
expensive for my income flow to keep up
with so yeah this whole plan kind of
didn't work but the junior coaster was
planned anyway and it's here to stay so
might as well build it at this point and
all of these layouts are getting
really similar I'm just trying to base
all of these junior coasters on the
typical standard for koma Junior
coasters that you see everywhere so if
the layouts start looking very similar
for each of these basically doing that
on purpose
I know it's not the most interesting
kind of layout to look at because all of
them just consist of simple helix based
layouts but that's just how these things
are in real life so I don't want to
deviate too much from that what is much
more interesting actually in this case
is I guess some of the scenery I'm
really trying to make this area look
very different from the starting area
much newer and a bit more bare-bones as
well because new areas and theme parks
they really tend to have much younger
foliage and everything just hasn't grown
quite as much doesn't usually have as
much detailing like little stalls and
path elements everywhere so everything
over here is a bit more minimalistic and
modern and sleek if you will now I'm
finally building the mega coaster again
and about the terminology officially the
instrument which is the company that
builds these cause the coaster type a
mega coaster they are considered a hyper
coaster if there are 200 feet or higher
they're considered a Giga coaster if
there are 300 feet or higher and they're
considered a strata coaster if they're
400 feet or higher which only some of
the launched coasters are like king.com
for instance so it's a bit weird because
there's very loose and narrow
definitions of what a hyper coaster
really is but in this case I think you
know I'm not entirely sure because park
attacks doesn't work in feeds and you
can't exactly measure the distance of
the ground like that not to mention that
something inevitably kind of gets lost
in the scaling of the game but this is
pretty much all things considered a
hyper coaster I think very much inspired
by Hyperion in my case although this
coaster type is also in real life used
for in simulators 305 and sky rush for
example and sky rush is actually a
coaster which is a super similar color
scheme to this one I was initially
actually not thinking of sky rush when I
came up with this color scheme I was
just
moving through different colors and I
ended up with this specific combination
of blue and yellow but for me this just
looks best I tried a good bunch of color
schemes but this is the one that stuck
out to me most it's slightly different
to the sky rush one though the sky rush
one has much brighter and more pale
colors but yeah the layout is actually
not that sky rush II it's definitely
much more like Hyperion which is a
slightly more out-and-back hyper coaster
but at the same time it's also very much
compact and it has a lot of turns and
very small airtime Hills it's not
necessarily my favourites intamin
coaster but it's one that works out very
well in this limited space I think not
to mention that you know I'm also
building these coaster layouts very much
to put their Park on on a pedestal for
everybody who's driving through the
highway just because you'll have these
these big skylines of hyper coasters
next to the highway so that's just a way
to draw people into the park you know
these are pretty much my operating
advertisements for the park to try and
lure all of those truck drivers and cars
into actually visiting this place so
obviously I want to put my biggest and
baddest coasters right next to the
highway here which I guess is also
something that a lot of real theme parks
will do especially in the US where you
get parks like Six Flags and Cedar
Point's putting some really big coasters
next to the parking lots or entrance
areas and this is kind of the same thing
except in real life you obviously never
have a theme park which actually
straddles two sides of a highway and I
say that but it actually does exist
I think ravine flyer too does this for
instance is a coaster that goes across
the highway
there are definitely examples of this
but it's not as common but yeah the
coaster is pretty much finished at this
point I had to keep the layout quite
short because for some reason the
friction of this closed to type is
actually a bit higher than it would be
in real life I think this thing tends to
slow down very quickly I still manage to
get a decent layout out of it I think
but overall its it's not a very long
coaster
and it goes back into the station quite
quickly because I also don't want the
second half of the right to be too slow
so there there's not too much to the
layouts and then everything when it
comes to the scenery around this is all
just very modern and minimalistic I'm
also using some slightly different
foliage and fences and all these kinds
of smaller elements to really help set
this part of the park apart from the
older part which I did realize having a
monorail coaster in the older part
doesn't make much sense because that's a
very relative relatively recent coaster
type but I don't know maybe this exists
in a parallel universe where the
monorail coaster was built earlier than
it is or maybe this is a park in the
future something like that anyway that's
just about it for this park so let's
return to an unpassed mode and to see if
we can make the objectives alright so as
you can see we need to hold the goals
for well three weeks that was originally
to win the scenario so it is another one
of these so we'll be reaching the
objectives very soon but basically this
is the end result of this park and
actually I'm quite happy with this
despite not really having a theme per se
I think there are some pretty charming
areas to this park like the Main Street
/ Boulevard area here with these facades
as well as the the area with the vintage
cars and just a new area even though it
looks very different I think very well
fits into the rest of the park as well
and having the skylines of these
coasters line the sides of the highway I
think is really cool too so I'm just
gonna get to the end of the scenario and
then I'll do a last POV of this coaster
here which interestingly to return to
that whole discussion about different
coaster types and Giga coasters and
hyper coasters and mega coasters the
game considers this a Giga coaster which
I guess is a very loose definition which
is just generally based on what coaster
type this is but again this I think this
is not really a Giga coaster because
usually when people talk about Giga
coasters they mean a coaster which is
300 feet in
it's but yeah these these definitions
always kind of depend but just the
overall trend is a coaster that doesn't
invert and that kind of goes out and
back with a lot of airtime and that's
basically what this coaster is doing
anyway we reach the objectives so I
think it's finally a good time to do a
quick POV of this coaster and I know I
keep calling it a POV even though I know
it's sort of off right but for me even
though I don't want to break the
isometric perspective I do think it's
really fun to follow the coasters along
like this so yeah we go from a very
steep drop into a quick tight curve here
which calls a lot of G's very similar to
intimate three or Intimidator 305 into a
small airtime Hill there which is kind
of like the the thing that Hyperion
tends to do a lot and then some airtime
Hills alongside a highway here of course
which according to the game don't pull
that many negative G's but I think you
might definitely get some really good
airtime in this it looks kind of like
ejector airtime but then again I'm not
entirely sure how to tell exactly how
much g-forces you pull on a certain
elements but just from looking these
definitely look like some good airtime
Hills and it started to rain again of
course I haven't mentioned this during
the time lapses but the rain was
actually a major contribution to why I
was struggling to finish this scenario
because while I was trying to make a
profits it kept raining and every time
it rained people wouldn't ride the the
monorail coaster and this is the only
right that made a substantial profits so
because of that it was very difficult to
actually get enough money to build the
hyper coaster without you know letting
the game run for a bit
while I was absent so yeah I don't know
the rain kind of rained on my parade for
this one but I mean I made it in the end
so I'm happy with the end result but
yeah that's basically the park and
actually let's check out the trophy that
we get for this one I remember that you
actually get the bridge plus a part of
the highway but Ananta sure let's
quickly save this end result here and
quits to the main screen but yeah I
think we actually get a highway here
which should be pretty cool alright so
there it is that's
the bridge and then it comes down in
there we don't actually get a highway
next to it but oh we do oh that's super
cool actually came down later and we
even get some cars driving on it whoa
that's cool and the next scenario is
gonna be Oh Orchard acres well that's
one that I've seen quite a few finished
results of that's gonna be a fun one but
I'm not gonna get to that yet I'm sorry
for kind of teasing that one for now I
really really need to get to Biscayne
Beach I think because that's a very
popular scenario and it's one that I've
been looking forward to try for a long
time it's also notoriously difficult so
we'll see how that goes but yeah that's
something to look at in the next episode
for now I want to end this by giving all
of you guys a reminder that I just set
up a discord server at last it was kind
of random that I finally just decided to
make one very impulsive decision but if
you're down to talk about Park attacked
with some other people or with me then
you should totally check out my discord
server out put an invite link in the
description of this video and yeah we
basically talk about planet coaster and
parkzicht and city skylines and
basically all the videos that I make on
my channel so maybe I'll see you guys
there but in any case I hope to see you
guys in the next episode in Biscayne
Beach bye guys